[Music]
what does the future of work look like
offices around the world are
reorganizing themselves
but not everyone wishes to return to
fixed workplaces once the pandemic
allows it
some have acquired a taste for working
from home
others still miss the physical divide
between the job and home life
and employers have mixed opinions too
many want to support allowing employees
the freedom to decide when and where
they work
for others this freedom is actually the
start of a free fall
into chaos
[Music]
welcome to your covet 19 special i'm
chris kober in berlin in march 2020 many
companies didn't have a choice the
raging coronavirus pandemic forced
governments to enact strict social
distancing rules overnight many offices
were shot and companies started a huge
remote working experiment
now that vaccine drives have been
underway at least in industrialized
nations and emerging economies how much
of remote working is here to stay
all he needs are a computer and an
internet connection
carlo almendral doesn't need an office
like many other filipinos he escaped the
lockdown in the capital manila to work
remotely on the beach
i didn't realize how
stressed out and anxious i was about the
pandemic until i got here and started
walking around on the beach with a mask
on and realized that like nobody else is
kind of doing it
[Music]
many have discovered the digital nomad
lifestyle
and it's hard for them to go back
some have let go of desk work completely
preferring a much more untethered model
welsh call center consultant jason
griffin wants to show the world that
work can be performed from literally
anywhere at all
provided there's enough battery power
it's a message he wants to share widely
the traditional five days in the office
monday friday nine to five they're gone
they're not here anymore people are
going to be split between home and
office if not home all the time and it's
exciting because
it fits people's life so much better
everything's going to be better
but the problem is not everyone may be
on board
the big problem that the major players
have is that they believe that the
best work can be done when the people
are bundled together in the one office
so to speak so there's going to be a
little bit of a tension there
and tensions can rise too when one is
forced to work from home and care for
children stuck there too
the yap family in taiwan knows all too
well having to concentrate on the job
and household chores while keeping
children engaged is a challenge
i'm so bored online learning is doing
all the things i did at school at home
i feel lazy because there's no one to
push me
but once it's safe to leave home will
offices ever be full again
in germany a minority can imagine
working exclusively from home
over 30 percent only want to work in the
office
but a significant majority prefers a mix
of office life and telecommuting
for now who gets which model will differ
from person to person and what their
bosses say
let's get more on this from sharon
parker she's the director of the center
for transformative work design at curtin
university's future of work institute in
perth australia welcome to dw sharon um
in the early days of the pandemic you
co-authored a research paper and in it
you outlined four key challenges to
people working remotely work home
interference ineffective communication
procrastination and loneliness have
these improved throughout the last
months
thanks chris yeah great question and i
guess the answer to that is they've
improved for some people but not
necessarily all people and that's i
guess one of the important things about
remote work during this time that people
have had very different experiences
and you know you know this from dinner
party conversations and so on if you're
someone who's at home in a small
apartment and you've got young children
and you know you haven't got your own
workspace and so on then those
challenges that you mentioned you know
can be really huge and daunting but for
other people who haven't had perhaps the
same situations
they've loved working from home and
thrived on it and actually you know are
talking about wanting to have more
working from home into the future so
people's experience have been very
diverse but absolutely some people have
experienced those challenges that you
mentioned
right i mean despite these diverse
experiences a microsoft report found
that almost 80 percent of those surveyed
said they would like to continue working
from home at least to some degree after
the pandemic
is that likely to happen
yeah and actually our own research
suggested very similar numbers uh of
people
um is it likely to happen uh actually
interestingly here in perth is a bit of
a test case because as i mentioned we've
been out of lockdown for about a year
we are definitely seeing more hybrid
models of work because i guess a few
things have happened
workers have discovered some of them
that this is something they want to
continue they've built new skills
they've become more confident
technology has advanced during this time
actually the technology is much much
better for this sort of conversation
that we're having right now and also
companies have learned that they can
trust people that they can still have
productivity and so um
they've also learned they could save
some office costs so there's been a lot
of forces coming together to suggest
that we we won't probably go back to how
it was before
exactly what it will look like
it's still uncertain but i think there's
going to be a lot more hybrid working
around into the future
now speaking of technology i mean there
is a large chunk of people
that say uh they feel overworked they
feel exhausted partly because of a
dramatic increase in digital
collaboration including emails meetings
remote meetings chats
groups working together on documents if
remote working is here to stay
what does a redesign look like
well we need to whether people are
remote working or whether people are
working in the office we need to give
attention to
these aspects of work that we know from
decades of research affect people
psychologically and you mentioned their
workload so one of the things we've seen
during covert when people are working
from home a lot even simple things like
the fact that people don't have to
commute
sometimes people spend that time just
working more you know and then you've
got some of those challenges of things
like um
constant zoom meetings and back-to-back
zoom meetings and it's very fatiguing
it's very tiring and research shows that
it's more tiring than those face-to-face
conversations
for all sorts of reasons
so you know what going into the future
we're going to have to pay serious
attention to that and say okay how do we
make sure that those workloads are
manageable that people are switching off
that we are giving people proper breaks
between meetings and so on and that's
this topic of work redesign and it's
it's been important for a long time in
in work in the office and it's going to
become a more important topic
for working from home into the future as
well let me ask you is all of this a
debate in very rich countries how much
working from home is possible in regions
where technological standards are much
lower
yeah you're absolutely right in a sense
we've got a privileged position um um
compared to
to some countries but also some jobs um
you know not all jobs can be done from
home as we know and we've talked a lot
about essential workers and and the
pressures that they've been under during
this covert um and i have to say you
know in the early days we we spent a lot
of time of of the pandemic saying well
actually we're lucky we we're sort of
talking about these struggles of remote
working but actually we've got a job you
know we've got a job that can be done at
home
um you know and we we've got health and
all those other things so sometimes you
do have to put these things in
perspective but i think the most
important point is that whether you work
from home whether you work in the office
there's things that you can do to make
work better and that's what we've got to
focus on you know teach our managers
educate our managers and others to
create work in which people um you know
have got reasonable workloads have got
some autonomy
you know and do those things that we
know really enable people to thrive and
flourish in their work
sharon parker of curtin university in
perth australia thank you for your
insights
whether we like it or not working from
home has kept many of us out of crowded
subways or buses during our commute and
away from potentially infectious office
meetings thereby lowering the risk of
catching the coronavirus
but we have to leave the house at some
point right and how protected are we
then here's one of your questions to our
science correspondent derek williams
how likely are to catch covid19 outside
for example from someone running by
for me one of the most striking aspects
of this pandemic is the amount of
research that's gone into trying to
answer
seemingly simple questions like this
which turn out to actually be
pretty incredibly complex i mean who
would have guessed even a year ago
that we'd have gotten so
obsessed with the highly abstract world
of aerosol distribution physics both
in enclosed rooms and outside back to
the question though we we now know that
while it certainly might be possible to
catch covet 19 outdoors
it's much much less likely than it is
indoors in poorly ventilated spaces
where people spend extended periods of
time that's because unlike outdoors
aerosols accumulate in enclosed spaces
and increase the chance
that you might inhale enough of of what
an infected person has exhaled
to catch the disease so
though that's an amount i'd like to note
by the way that we we still don't know
with any certainty
in general
the consensus seems to be that in
addition to the indoors outdoors aspect
of the equation
the other factors that play major roles
in infection are
how long exposure lasts
how close
an infected person comes to you
and the amount of time that you're
around them
the who only recommends masks in outdoor
settings
where physical distancing can't be
maintained
like crowds
and not for people doing intense
physical activity that's because pretty
much all the indicators point to the
conclusion
that the jogger panting by you in the
park
just doesn't really present that big of
a risk
[Music]
you